[Music]
foreign
just like Russia Russia Russia just like
the fake dossier was a hoax I'm an
innocent man I'm an innocent person
[Music]
it does seem if we accept the
truthfulness of many of the stories
appearing in the newspapers that they've
got a wealth of evidence that Mr Trump
knew about where these documents were
that he was plotting to try to hide them
they've got video they've got people who
are involved in moving around they even
have a story that they went through
dress rehearsal as to how they could
conceal some of these documents from the
federal authorities
[Music]
thank you
it was striking to witness that when he
was indicted in New York on the charges
arising out of the Stormy Daniels Affair
and the the the classification of those
expenditures his poll numbers actually
improved the normal political
assumptions that apply seemingly don't
apply in the same way to Donald Trump so
help me God
foreign
[Music]